bienvenido a france 24 señor ortiz es
bien sabido que durante las pasadas
elecciones los jóvenes han sido parte de
la extensionismo pero teniendo en cuenta
el contexto de los últimos dos años
realmente los veremos participando en
las urnas
yo creo que sí yo creo que las y los
jóvenes van a participar más en estos
comicios electorales precisamente por
las condiciones históricas que estamos
viendo como país aún así que vaya a ser
un incremento significativo de la
participación no lo creería
particularmente porque no sólo los
jóvenes sino toda la población tiene una
fuerte desconfianza por el sistema
representativo que estamos tener en
colombia muy pocas personas confiar en
la presidencia en el congreso y esto
pasa también en los jóvenes muy pocos de
ellos o sea ninguna de esas instancias
representativas supera el 20 por ciento
de confianza en las los jóvenes por lo
que yo creería que la participación en
esos comicios se incrementará
precisamente por el momento histórico
que estamos viviendo pero no será
significativamente mayor ahora sí cuáles
serían entonces los factores que motiven
a los jóvenes a tener una mayor
participación en estas votaciones
los menciones de ahorita particularmente
las y los jóvenes están buscando que se
les reconozca de acuerdo con la encuesta
nacional de punto que nosotros hicimos
el 75 por ciento de las y los pone
sienten que los políticos no los
escuchan y ese es un factor determinante
para poder votar como cualquier otro
escenario cuando tú vas a invertir en un
negocio presente a saber que la otra
parte tiene en cuenta tus intereses y
eso lo que no está pasando ahorita en el
sistema político colombiano en ese
sentido yo creo que de hecho la
necesidad de reconocimiento lo que está
determinando particularmente la
intencionalidad de voto de las los
jóvenes obviamente todavía seguirán las
agendas de trabajo educación de tener
uso del tiempo libre pero todas esas
agendas van a estar comenzada van a
comenzar a estar marcadas precisamente
por la necesidad de reconocimiento y de
que se pongan a las y los jóvenes en el
centro de la gestión como actores
políticos válidos que pueden incidir en
estos espacios ahora cómo influirá el
voto joven en estas elecciones de mateo
puede influir bastante es el 25 por
ciento más o menos del censo electoral
ahora
que sea determinante no lo es
precisamente porque es el 25 pero puede
influir bastante en los resultados pero
mucha gente que lo que tiende a pensar
es precisamente que el voto joven es un
voto más o menos de izquierda cuando
realmente no lo es pero el 33 por ciento
más o menos de las y los pones
identifican con esa 40 ideológica la
mayor parte está en el centro y a un
incremento significativo de la derecha
ahorita disolvemos ahora un historiador
de cifras conceptos por lo que
precisamente hacia donde saber interés
auto joven es lo que vamos a tratar de
terminar porque aquí hay una figura muy
interesante un candidato que ha venido
repuntando que es curiosa precisamente
porque nadie lo esperaba bueno y además
de acudir a las urnas en las próximas
citas electorales veremos cada vez más
gente joven involucrándose en la
política que cree usted
yo creo que sí pero es que lo bienvenido
haciendo yo creo que el tema es que la
sociedad no lo ha sabido ver muchos
jóvenes y eso es un dato importante
creo que el grupo poblacional que más
involucra precisamente en organizaciones
comunitarias en las organizaciones
locales que son precisamente
transformación a nivel local como por
ejemplo temas de protección barrial
temas de protección animal protección
ambiental todos esos temas son muy
interesantes para nuestros jóvenes y
ellos históricamente han participado
precisamente estas organizaciones
comunitarias el problema es que nosotros
no vemos eso como participación y ese es
un gran como una situación de estigma
que se le pone a las los buen esenciales
es que no participan pero si lo hacen el
problema es que no confían en el sistema
tradicional ahora con lo que está
pasando con la ley 16 vendidos expresión
bueno lo que está pasando 1622 es que
precisamente aparece el sistema nacional
de puertos y se espera que precisamente
el involucramiento de jóvenes en
política pública sea mayor